mercedes has recently appeared to be
targeting younger drivers
there's the latest a-class and the
all-new cla
with some serious engine power appeal
and this is also the first time ever the
mercedes-benz's performance division amg
has ventured into the compact class
on the outside at least the cla looks
like a sedan version of the a-class
its maker classes it as a coupe
our car tester sash is trying out the
most powerful four-cylinder engine in
series production anywhere
found under the hood of the cla 45 amg
it boasts a maximum output of 265
kilowatts and 450 newton meters of
torque
sounds promising as the engine is eager
to confirm
that's some power coming out of the
modest 2-liter displacement
sasha notes that common elements with
the sls amg
the air inlets and the gear knob the
speedometer
goes up to 320 kilometers per hour but
the top
speed is electronically limited to 250.
if you're prepared to invest an extra
couple thousand euros then you're up to
kilometers per hour
the cla amg makes the sprint to 100
kilometers per hour in a dashing 4.6
seconds
fuel consumption is officially just 6.9
liters of premium unleaded for 100
kilometers although to actually achieve
that level of efficiency
you'd have to drive way under the car's
performance potential
the amg version is a driver's car says
chief designer focus
his team wanted the elements that the
driver needs to be functional
and nice-looking the instrument cluster
had to be easy to read the steering
wheel had to be pleasant to hold
and also afford a good view of the road
plus it has paddles for direct shifting
and the performance seats provide solid
support for active driving
in terms of lateral acceleration and
side support
you have the whole car nicely under
control
the cla amg is a high performance
vehicle
it's fitted with amg seven gear speed
shift dct sports transmission
with three driving programs in manual
and sports modes
the shift times rival those of the sls
amg grand tourer
experienced racing drivers have the
option of switching off the esp
and the esp curve dynamic assist the
sport suspension has larger stabilizers
and reduces role when navigating fast
double bends
so what about the ride for rear seat
passengers
sasha says it feels as uncomfortable as
it looks the driver and front passenger
are kept in place by these firm sport
seats
at the back you're kept in place by the
roof and the seat in front
there's precious little leg room or
headroom
not that surprising actually given the
coupes plunging roofline
design was evidently given priority over
comfort here
mercedes wanted the cla to be part of
the amg brand reveals folker helbig
that meant making the brand design
clearly visible
there's the twin blade radiator grille
the mark of an authentic amg
then his design team worked on the
technical functions
the cooling and aerodynamics
the front splitter down below generates
down force
all these features make the vehicle a
recognizable amg
the rear with its flowing contours bears
strong parallels to the car's much
bigger brother the cls
the cla amg is standard fitted with
variable all-wheel drive
in regular driving conditions it prefers
the front axle which translates into
greater efficiency
if you need more power the system can
distribute 50 percent of the power to
the rear wheels
sasha finds the suspension unsuitable
for pothole
roads but when you're negotiating fast
curves the car grips the pavement well
he's impressed
the cla amg then is a car for speed
not a comfortable ride and there's
another drawback
putting a mercedes cla 45 amg through
its paces doesn't come cheap
note sasha it costs around 56 000 euros
the regular cla 29 000 the question
is whether you really need 265 kilowatts
of power
or whether you're content with a more
modest appearance and output
and vinegar
ultimately the financial aspect might be
decisive
the cla 45 amg is for people who really
enjoy driving
and who have a sizable amount of cash at
their disposal
you